[موسيقى]
الشتاء 90 يوما مقسمه على بدايه وشده
ونهايه فبدايته مع موسم الصفري في شهر
سبتمبر وشدته مع موسم المربعانيه والشرطه
في شهر ديسمبر ويناير ونهايته مع موسم
الحميم في شهر ابريل والعامه يقسمون 90
يوما من باب التقريب كالتالي 40 يوما
المربعانيه و50 يوما مقسمه على الشبط
والعقارب فبرد اول الشتاء مضر على الاجساد
وبرد اخر شتاء نافع للاشجار توقوا البرد
في اوله وتلقاه في اخره فانه يعمل في
الاجساد كعمله في الاشياء فاوله محرق
واخره
موري
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
و خلال هذه الايام يدخل علينا ثاني نجوم
الشبط المسماه عند العرب القدماء بالبلده
والعامه يسمونه شباط ثاني ومدته 13 يوما
وفيه تنتشر مواشي في طلبي ارزاقها لا تبكي
هم الرزقي فهو مقدر و العبد طوال حياته
مرزوق واحفظ لسانك عن اذيه مسلم فسبابه
قال الرسول
فسوقوا
[موسيقى]